[Music]
even if i've been home for two months
everything's still new
they call me ap poppy now what's up
y'all [ __ ] boy ronnie rubble y'all
watching on the rocks with gq
all right so boom
i like this ring this ring is nice it's
cute i put this on my pinky all the time
but this right here is really my special
range right that i love
i had these customs with orange in them
all right
so i'm ready rebel y'all know so i put
double i put always in my rings for one
for riley one for rebel
i fifteen piece they both two-toned rose
going white
but one background is different on one
one setting background is different you
got one all white and rose going in the
top head then you got one
all rose gold with white on the top here
eric the jeweler everything eric the
jeweler i don't go nowhere else
shout out to eric the jeweler he made my
cooler
let me tell you why i said that right
this is my first piece when i got home
i had my links ready so i'm going to
give me the band
but i could switch the band up any time
i want so my my links finally got ready
i just got a whole new watch just kept
this one still
so i got this one right here
before you load it draw with the link on
it two tones there
you know ap poppy they call me
all right look come here we should have
something special
this right here i call it coke rebel
like the wicked side of me and my demon
side of me
my eagle side my side drew this picture
for me and i sent it to you
i doubted my son too all the bros was
like y'all cause i said the bro the
picture
drew you're like yo you serious what's
that you gotta come better than that i'm
like yo trust me
but i have faith for my boy you know we
had to prove that that was wrong
all right so this is the picture right
here originally
look at the details of the picture and
you're gonna look at the details in the
chain
and tell me if my boy didn't do his
thing or not man i mean i think i made
the piece better than the picture to be
real with you
let's talk about it let's talk about it
basically obviously there's money my man
got a money tattoo
how did that come about
um just you know us on the block playing
around with our words just always
having our own ideas our own creativity
we used to go out partying a lot like we
used to always say cash on deck
cash on deck floyd was like the money
team the money team so
my son kate tom schwenny team 20 team
schweinsteiger team be like like
schmurder shredder schmutz i was like
oh that's fire and just we just started
like playing with lingo and it just
it just came about and he's just stuck
with it we got the money over there
obviously rowdy got braids it's the full
brace from computers
yeah four basic computers you know we
see the um
flush tearing apart over here so this
piece is special because
it actually took a lot of my time a lot
of stress
behind it and also my boy was kind of
doubting me
i was in jail nervous you know you're in
jail like come on e
i ain't ready yet all right this is just
a lie
i'm gonna keep it real with you guys i
finished this piece the day you got out
it wasn't even ready a week before or a
month before
like this piece literally got done an
hour before he got out
i was late to the jet i was actually
supposed to deliver it to the jet
because even we was at the chat yeah it
was so much some
pandemonium so much chaos there i was
just running around so much
but when i was getting my hair done and
everything was calm and i was settled
and then your he just pulled down i'm
like wow yeah well yeah
i didn't even know about the glow in the
dark and all that
evil so i got home i added that on top
like last minute i'm like you know what
you gotta add a little little sauce to
this yeah that was fun
honestly my personal opinion and i don't
know if it's other people's opinion but
this is probably one of the best pieces
of 2020.
you know that's my opinion but
that's fires
a couple of my favorite bus downs we got
a factory rainbow daytona
this costs 450 000. this is my wrench
right here
it's the protect two-tone patty blue
face
factory blue face right here right here
don't touch the face you know i like the
blue just like that
think about confidence which i think
i've been riding with the jewelry so far
i might chill right
you know i need a couple more pieces
every time you make some money reward
yourself
yeah the end of the day jewelry is one
of those things where it's like you're
not really throwing your money in the
garbage
you throw money in the garbage and you
buy bottles at the club
i'm saying spend money on clothes you're
buying gold and diamonds and golden
diamonds is always worth money you know
you're buying watches watchers or
investments that's a fact
i appreciate you for coming through my
boy should snatch one of your watches
over you
uh it's all white bulgarian
got this for me right here bro there's
some players
i talked to lebron facetime and the
jeweler man was
in the um studio
and he had put two chains on my neck and
it was
i just put it on my neck just to see how
i look in it i was talking to talk about
your thoughts check me out look how i
look bro
he like getting mean on you keep those
on you
i'm like i'm like yeah i ain't about to
pay for this i don't got it he like
not you know me you're good keep those
on don't take those off
i'm like oh he's on you big bro he like
yeah that's what i mean no cap
shout out to thought though that's the
twin that's the brown man
cardio you can't party here i all my
brothers do cartiers
oh you can't party here these bugettis
are the joints you got vbs in the
background
too blue wood tips
these 10 000 right here on the face
talk to me nice i've really been wilding
right
so this is like the energy board i just
got
i mean i'm not even going busters i
don't know time soon
i'm gonna wait till i get my pieces
around this is our emeralds in this like
uh um
got the blue jaw for the ripsters
all right this is a piece right here i'm
thinking about getting attacked
on this drawing i think it's like i
think it says 25 000 for this
i ain't ready to spend 25 000 yet but
i'm gonna need to get it because
this piece right here i've been working
on getting so i was like
i'm gonna need a piece for it but i'm
gonna change the
color if i do decide to get it i got it
in my jewelry box though because
that's how much i [ __ ] with my boy you
know if all if i ain't gonna cop it for
him
i just come bring it back here's my
right hand right here this right hand
side statement right here this one right
here
that boy back home don't play with him
oh
everything gotta make sense now we've
been away for a little minute so now
that we back we don't want to rush
things out there
we still don't know what we're working
with we still wanted people around us we
still learn how to trust who to
give our music to who to have around
it's a lot
man balancing out the personal life in
this music
but what's next for rowdy man just know
y'all gonna always see my face doing
something
extravagant every time i see rowdy it's
gonna be a movie they're gonna be
excited
they're gonna sit in front of our phones
scroll back up again to my page and do
it all over
hi man it's your boy roddy hey yo good
looking for watching my interview on the
rocks you alright
boom